she said this is serious we are praying
for you and after she prayed prince said
amen
wow it's a miracle perhaps she's the
longest free fall without a parachute
my life flashed before my eyes all i
knew was i had multiple organ failure
and my body was shutting down
and this one particular doctor stayed
with me and he had to restart my heart
three times in the middle of the night
she actually did pass away very briefly
and they brought her back
you look at each other
uh i just said
thank you
chapter one girl who fell from the sky
by stanley ann brooks
and that's the true story of julianne
kepcke who in 1972 was living in peru
going to the american school
she was 18 was in her senior year
her parents were noted zoologists she
had lived part of her childhood in the
amazon
her parents were cataloging butterflies
and bats
and then when she got to middle school
they moved her to lima and she grew up
there spoke perfect german perfect
english perfect spanish
and uh because it was uh
they're on a different schedule than us
because their seasons are different than
us
uh their school year ends in december
so she was both graduating and going to
her prom
in december and uh her dad wanted them
to go
to the amazon uh on christmas
eve and she wanted to stay and so
he went early and she and her mom stayed
behind in lima and she
went to her prom graduated with her
friends and then they got on a plane
and when the plane was over the amazon
it was hit by lightning twice
and disintegrated in midair and she was
in the window seat still strapped in
and as she said the i didn't leave the
plane the plane left me and she found
herself
uh at 15 000 feet in her chair upside
down
pinwheeling and uh she
fell blacked out fell hit the canopy of
the amazon which broke her fall
it's a miracle perhaps she's the longest
free fall without a parachute
and the canopy broke her fall and she
uh landed in the amazon woke up had
nothing but a broken collarbone
that she knew of she had one shoe lost
her glasses
and for the next nine days followed
the river and the lessons that she
learned from her father and
her own desire not to die and
was rescued and she's a friend of mine
now she's now in her 50s
and she's an extraordinary woman she
spends half her year in munich
and the other half of the amazons trying
to save the rainforest
and uh we're gonna go down to bogota
and uh and and the amazon and hopefully
tell that story at the beginning next
year
wow chapter two two teachers
by bill duke i grew up as a racist
i hated all white people because of
slavery and
segregation so my father and mother go
through i just
hated white i just and i grew up an
angry young black man and i was tall and
awkward and
i didn't talk much and i wrote journals
and stuff
and um these two old people i'll never
forget
it changed my life mrs jean walker
english teacher
very stoic and like just walking around
the class
she told me nine times that's right in
my journal when she was teaching i just
ignored her this
racist white woman
and one day
she says do stay here after class
just give me that book i said what the
general give it to me
i said i'm not giving anything she said
if you don't give me the journal
i'll fail in the class and you can't
pass
through the general ladder pissed off
hated her come back to class the next
several weeks before
spring break and looked at her like
if i could punch your damn face man
spring break ends come back to class
into the first days i'm going into class
she says duke come here
she gives me back my journal and this
book
i said what is this
she says the national poetry contest
book
so what do you want what are you giving
this to me for she says look on page 49.
she put two of my poetry poems in there
and it won
i looked at her this is somebody i hated
she had taken she read my book
my journal took the best poems out
and submitted them to a national poetry
contest and i won
i was speechless and she knew i was
speechless
she says there's nothing to say
you're good at what you do
that changed my mind i wasn't quite sure
how to think about
race then because that never happened to
me
and then i went to dusty community
college
and you know
james hall was the dean he was in the
navy and stuff and
i got in a scholarship to boston
university after duchess and then
but you know it was difficult i got a
scholarship
for my classes but i had to work
for room and board and food and
everything i was working seven days a
week
exhausted and my grades weren't that
great and separate
just going to the arts college
i decided i was going to come home to
poughkeepsie and i was going to
stay there for a year quit vu
and get a job make money so i can save
it for that at ibm
i went during the summer up to visit my
friends at
bu and i'm leaving dr hall
uh see he says hey duke come here i said
i gotta go doc
he says duke come here come here
jesus guy's a boring ass white man i
can't stand this
i go into those offices to be courteous
he says have a seat
i said okay how are you doing duke
okay you go to boston university right
yeah well i'm not i'm i'm i'm going but
i'm
quitting i'm staying in mckinsey for a
year and going to go back next year
he says no you're not
what are you talking about
he goes into his vest pocket and he has
a novel up to me
i said what does that say open it
in the envelope it was a check
of his own money that paid for three
years
of my room and board at boston
university
i looked in this man's white man's face
i'm supposed to hate
he doesn't say a word we look at each
other
uh i just said
thank you he did not say a word
he put out his hand and he said don't
disappoint me
see something happens to your racism
after that
this supposed to be your evil enemy
that's responsible for the
negative in your life and everything the
devil the
system the creature
just gave me a check to cover
all of my expenses for three years
how do you hate that
life-changing
so i evolved you know
in my humanity to understand you cannot
put a blanket
on any of everything of anything
it's all about the human being the
person the individual who they really
are behind
what their skin color is behind what
their words are their position it makes
no difference
to know the human if they respect you
you respect them
simple arab chinese japanese
jewish white black green hispanic
those topical services that's
a limited perception
you have the courage to uh engage people
at their level of humanity
you're living it's easier to dismiss you
because
i see you when i make assumptions
i learned a long time ago
a-s-s-u-m-e means
it makes the ass out of you and the ass
out of me
to assume
and i was taught by those two incidents
it was incredible
it wasn't for those two people i
wouldn't probably be here today
and never asked for anything
all they said is to be your best
that's a reward
that's the truth
chapter 3 thank god they professionals
by rameen johnson
i was living uh i wasn't doing a show at
the time but i was living
on the other side of town and my dad was
sick in the hospital
and my mother and i actually had my car
at that point
and my mother was at the hospital all
day she said well you know what um
i just don't feel good you know being at
the house by myself can you come over
here and spend the night at house
oh of course i had my own apartment oh
yeah
so she said well look i've been in the
hospital all day i don't have no food i
haven't cooked
maybe you ought to stop at mcdonald's or
something and get you something i said
oh okay
and i stopped at the mcdonald's i went
through the drive-through it's kind of
late at night
and i ordered my food and the girl said
um
well can you uh pull over cause you know
we're cooking and bring it out to you
i said okay so i'm sitting in the car
and it's cold i'm
running my gas i'm like oh wait a minute
so i said well i'm gonna go inside so i
came inside and she look i said
i'm the guy you told her to pull over
she said oh okay so
they said we haven't even got it ready
yet so so i'm standing at the counter
and there's like four of us four guys at
the counter you know
getting our food and the little boy in
front of me you know the little
mcdonald's boy he's like
looking at me and all of a sudden he
looks over like this and he
starts doing this and i'm looking at him
like
what look you got i'm looking like what
he's it
and i look over a guy
got a sawed-off shotgun pointed right in
my head
and he's telling me raise your hands
my hands up and these guys proceeded to
rob the mcdonald's
and what he did was it was two one guy
came in on the other side the other door
the backup guy
and he uses me as a shield
and he's got the gun under my arm i like
my arms up
he puts the gun under here and he's got
the gun right
in the face of that little boy oh wow
and he says
empty the register and the little boy
naturally
he said empty the register so the
manager or female at this time she's
down here and the guy with the salt off
he says okay empty all the registers
she empties all the registers except
mine
and then he says okay open the safe and
she says well
i can't i don't have a combination it's
a dropbox she said no you can open the
safe
she says i can't open it they come every
night and get the money the security
come every night and get the money i
can't open it
he said you're lying he says get out on
the ground
she gets down on the ground
on the floor of the place and he leans
over the counter
and he the gun and he puts it on
the side of he says i'm going to tell
you
and i'm going to ask you one last time
open the safe
so she's like this and she's like oh she
starts crying please don't kill me i
can't hoping to save
i got a baby at home please it's just me
and my baby please please
and i'm like this and i'm just looking
and i'm just like oh my god
and i got the guy behind me with the
little boy like this and i'm like this
and i'm like oh and i'm like this and
all of a sudden
the guy uncocks the gun
and the next thing on my mind is thank
god
they're professionals professionals
don't want to shoot anybody see
i found that out from being in detroit
around the hood well
professionals don't want to shoot
anybody they want to get in and get out
so he says okay we're finished getting
the money
she jumps up she gets the money she gets
down to my registered little boy
this mcdonald's money and we said give
him the money
give him the money we yelling and
screaming and they say shut up we didn't
shut up give him the money give him the
money
it was just pandemonium so this
manager she knocks him out the way goes
in his register and get the money and
put it in one of the big mcdonald's bags
and hand it to the guy so the first guy
out of the place is the guy that had the
pistol under my arm the last guy out
he says anybody try anything i'm gonna
come back and kill everybody
he comes down the line of us they didn't
rob us he comes down the line of us
and takes the the the gun
across all our backs the smaller my back
i had this gun go down a small in my
back
and i'm telling you my life
flash before my eyes when people say oh
my life flash
i went from being a baby sitting in my
pants in my diaper
all the way up to them it was just like
that i'm like oh
and i'm like oh god oh oh oh like this
and he left
out when he left out they took off
running i looked they took off running
all of the customers jumped over the
counter and we were all behind the thing
by this time the cops came in because
they put
they pushed the silent alarm and
i got to the house and my mother said oh
she said you didn't get your food i'm
like no i didn't get it
so she says what's wrong i said we got
stuck up at mcdonald's
my mother's like oh okay my mother got
mad at me when i said
i have to remember what that felt like
because one day i'm gonna have to act
and have to
recreate that experience my mother got
mad at me
that was the end of that story but
that's what happened what
you in that damn acting and that's when
i really finally realized
this is it this is where i'm supposed to
be
chapter four prince's principles by alex
munoz
i moved to los angeles before i got
accepted to film school
and um i just figured if i don't get
into usc
or ucla afio you know
go assistant director or get a job at a
production company over the studio so
i um the second day i was in la i got an
internship with a company called
propaganda films
and on my second day of the job um
a casting director says hey um
what's your name and i said alex she
said oh her name is lisa fields and she
said um
would you like to be a stand-in for a
famous rock star i'm like
well who is it and she said well i can't
tell you i said no
i don't want to be a stand-in because i
want to be behind the camera so i went
back to my boss stephen price and
i said hey um lisa fields wants me to be
a standout for a rock star she won't
tell me who it is and
i don't want to do it and he said why i
said because i want to be a director i
don't want to be in front of the camera
i want to be behind the camera he said
you have to do it
you've never been on a professional film
set so i raced back
and she was on the phone and ready to
hire somebody i said i'll do it i'll do
it she said okay
so the next day i'm on the set and
the dp says okay alex you can leave now
and i turn around
and i'm face to face with prince and
i'm like i really wasn't a big prince
fan at the time but i was looking down
at him
and our noses were like this far apart
i'm like wow
you've got four heels on and i'm taller
than you
and he just laughed and he goes can we
switch places and i said sure
so um anyway we were told not to talk to
prince he said do not talk to him
but he would talk to me and on day six i
got
my letter of acceptance from usc
and my roommate got the letter
and she said i have something really
important to give you i said okay while
i'm in downtown l.a and
i'm on this music video should can you
bring it so she gave me the letter i
opened it up and i
went into the set and i said i was
really excited i said i got into usc
film school
and everyone started clapping and prince
said
i'm like what he goes come here i'm like
well what did i do
so he said um so you're going to be a
filmmaker
i said yes he said let me hear you say
that
i said say what he said let me hear you
say you're going to be a filmmaker
and i said i'm going to be a filmmaker
and he said i want you to
listen closely there are four roles i
want you to consider abiding by
if you are going to pursue filmmaking in
this town
i said okay so he said first one always
you point it up
always remember god the creator always
remember god
and your creator number two always
remember where you come from
because when you forget where you come
from you die as an artist
and then number three was
break the rules if you follow the rules
you're going to be bowing and you're
going to fade fast
and number four was always give back
you must give back as an artist
and i said okay and he said repeat
repeat what i said and i did
i call these my four purple cornerstones
remember god where you come from um
never forget uh where you come from
i'm sorry let me start over i will
always remember
the four i call them my four purple
cornerstones
remember god and the creator never
forget where you come from
break the rules and always always give
back and he said grace is really
important in your journey
so after he tested me on the four
you know core principles he told me he
told rosie gaines his backup singer he
said rosie
pray for this brother that he does not
go down the dark path
he needs to stay on the path of light
so rosie gaines took my hands
placed them on prince's piano
and pray made a prayer a protection that
i wouldn't be seduced by the dark side
you know
all the what prince called the fleshly
temptations and she said this is serious
we are praying for you
and after she prayed prince said amen
wow
and he said don't forget what i told you
i said i won't
so imagine that
is a priceless
encounter that cannot be measured i
just moved to la i just i finished my
undergraduate work at santa barbara
for him to take the time to tell me
these things and share with me
his four core principles and for him to
ask his backup singer rosie gaines to
pray for me
i never forget this and
one of the reasons why when i decided to
move forward with making fyi films in
non-profit
i rummaged through my mind i remember
prince saying always give back and he
helped me i don't think i'd be talking
about fy films if princeton tell me this
about giving back
the second part of the story is so when
prince died right they did a tribute
concert
for him and uh i called the organizers
and i said hi
um my name is alex munoz and prince gave
me some really good advice back in the
day
i will do anything i will sweep the
streets i will sell popcorn i would saw
hot dogs so i'd be an usher
i'll do security i just want to in my
own way pay tribute to this great artist
because he he gave me some advice that
i'll never ever forget
so they said we'll call you right back
and what happened was
two hours later they called back and
they said we googled you and you're a
filmmaker why
don't you do a film celebrating prince
and i said
well the concert's ten days away i can't
possibly make it good in a film
and i said how what if i document it so
i went to document this
prince tribute concert and
the very first interview i did is is
happened to be in the same exact spot
when prince told me
the four purple cornerstones it was like
oh my god this is where
prince told me to remember god
remember where you come from break the
bulls and always get back
and i felt really inspired
like my body was like trembling because
i was you could feel his presence
in that area was the concert where i was
right in front of
la city hall which is where they shot
the video how uncanny
is that then um
i went out to the audience and
interviewed some people about the
concert and stevie wonder does this
amazing
rendition of purple rain so i'm trying
to get backstage to interview stevie
and i can't get to him and the guards
are saying you can't talk to stevie he
doesn't want to be bothered
so one of my fy film alumni from hawaii
adrian kelly sees me and says hey um
alex what are you doing here and i said
oh
i think i told you when i taught fy
films
that when i taught the film workshop
that my first experience on a film set
was being princess standard he said yeah
yeah
but what are you doing here i said i'm
doing a documentary he said well why do
you look mad i said because
stevie gave the best performance and i
want to interview him and they won't let
me get backstage and he said
oh i could help you and i said adrian
that's really nice to you but you can't
help me.
he said alex i could help you he goes in
the back comes back and he says come on
takes me stevie wonder stevie wonder's
nephew
oh wow so
wow i felt like it was full circle
so i mean i got like chicken skin right
now because prince tells me
the importance of giving back i'm there
to do a documentary about this concert
i can't get to stevie it turns out one
of my alumni
never told me he'd be stevie wonder's
nephew
gets me backstage because i believe i
had access to stevie and all the
princess backup singers and all the
princess backup dancers
because if i didn't teach that fyi film
workshop in hawaii
i would have met adrian and then two
years later i see adrian at this concert
and he gets me backstage that's karma
that is oh i'm doing what i'm supposed
to be doing
and i told adrian i said why didn't you
ever tell me
you were stevie wonder's nephew he said
i don't know you know munoz
i don't want people my family we don't
want people to like us just because
we're related to stevie so we just
but but you earned it because you've
come to our birthday parties and our
full-time parties and you never asked
any questions and you showed us love
anyway so okay now you know
so i mean what what a blessing right
that
oh my gosh one of my alumni is stevie
wonder's nephew and little did i know
that two and a half years later i would
need him
to complete my doc right and you're in
the same spot
where you first met prince so it was a
music video back in the day
yes in front of l.a city hall yeah wow
chapter five
the cat house by jack perez we had a
feral cat
we've always had feral cats come to our
house because we have lots of cats
and a feral cat a wild cat will will
just sense that
cat people live there and a feral cat
obviously cannot be pet
or touched or anything they're wild
animals
but we've done this over the years and
we fed feral cats so
uh you know i guess a little over 10
years ago we were moving from our
apartment
and just as we were about to move a
feral cat showed up and it was like feed
me
and we were like yes of course we'll
feed you but we're moving
and we were faced suddenly with this
prospect of like what are we going to do
this this this animal is like dependent
upon us now but we're moving
it got to the point where i was like
literally driving across town every day
to leave food it's this empty house the
cat was standing it was the saddest
thing she's
he's like where's my food i'm like i'm
driving across town we i
can't keep this up i can't expect the
new tenants to to take care of him or
whatever so i started looking into
rescues and looking into
um that whole world and it's a you know
again i became educated was like wow
there's just there's just tons of kill
shelters if you bring an animal to a
regular shelter
likely they will be killed certainly a
feral who can never be adopted
rarely what do you do with a feral cat
and so after a lot of research i found
this one place which i'd never heard of
the cat house on the kings which was
this one woman's
massive property up near fresno that she
had turned in this ranch style
multi-acre property into this sanctuary
an adoption center where she had you
know almost a thousand
animals that were totally cared for it
wasn't an it wasn't a hoarder it was
like an operation
sure and she was like yeah you know we
actually have a feral
you know section and if you can catch
him
you know you can bring him here and i
was like wow and wherever
everybody else was like we're full up
and they'll kill him and all this was
the one place and
when i went up there it was like one
woman and a couple of you know maybe one
other person and
all of these animals and i was like this
was like the definition to me of like a
saint like this was like this woman who
had
dedicated her whole life to to these
animals literally and was like
making it work she definitely needed
help
but she and i i said to myself my god
well what
what can i do in exchange for this you
know you saved this cat's life and these
thousands of other dogs and cats
so i decided to make this youtube video
i said i'll come back and i'll do a
portrait of you and the place a couple
minutes and you know we'll put it on
youtube and this is when youtube was
sort of
new you know and and it just
we just as luck would have it there were
enough cat people out there that it
started to
go viral and people really saw that this
was a
this beautiful soul that was doing
something so unique and she started to
get donations and it started to get
more well known and now you know 10 13
years later it's a it's a it's
considered you know it's a very
well-known institution you know around
the world people come from all over the
world to visit
this place and support support it you
know my wife has said you know it's the
most important film
you ever made was that film for the cat
house because
you know talking about direct action
that film because it went viral because
i made it
because it exists and it reached people
that that institution that sanctuary
received
much needed donations that saved a lot
more animals and so
in terms of doing something that's
valuable
truly valuable that little film
you know when i think about it you know
is is you know
definitely up there as being an
important movie of mine just because
it helped it ultimately helped a lot of
animals
chapter six station fire by andy
rodziewski
do you still have the mini dv tapes no
unfortunately you know it's a bummer i
uh
about let's see this would have been 11
years ago
my house that was renting uh burned down
in one of the la
at the time the biggest fire in la and i
lost
all of my films i lost all my writing
all my art i used to
you know draw and it was
it was it still still kind of stings but
you know truthfully it was a big um
reset button i i it it has helped me
with uh attachment and having a lack of
it
uh it was the year after
my house burned down i just kind of
lived on the road for a year
i could fit everything i owned in a
backpack
and so i slept on couches i flew out to
hawaii
and slept on my buddy's hotel room while
we were working on a movie out there
like it was
my life was a bit of an adventure which
i think was
good i think it was it was an
interesting life for a time
uh but the at the sacrifice of
losing you know all basically everything
i had created
up until 30 years old essentially was
this the station fire
yeah the station fire yeah i remember it
yeah
yeah it was it was yeah it was a strange
time
strange time it's it's funny to think
that that's so long ago because it does
feel
so uh relevant to my life like it really
i'm
it's it's altered some of my
way of approaching things and and
purchases
feel strange to me still furniture and
i like owning things still feels a
little weird
a little ptsd i think but you know i i
my life has been good since then so it's
i just one of the stepping stones i
guess who knows
aside from it you losing all these
things and and that being
the horrible like negative side and
losing in a sense your
parts of yourself really went down in
that fire do you think it showed you how
temporary
things are and you look to things in a
new light in a positive way that way
yeah i would for sure say the silver
lining of losing everything
is that you the idea of impermanence
becomes
a lot easier to grasp and i for sure
it's the impermanence of everything life
health i mean friendships you know
you just never i think i take some of
those things
less for granted now perhaps i hope i
don't know
uh and i do wonder you know 20 years
from now
what will the scars of that look like
will they still be there will i
you know i don't know i moved into a
house a year ago
uh after living in someone else's house
for basically 10 years i had like a wing
of a house to myself
and uh when i moved into my place last
year
i owned nothing i had no bed i didn't
have a chair
a desk i had nothing and so 11 years
well 10 years i guess at the time after
the fire
was the first time that i was like okay
i got to purchase
some things and it felt it still feels
odd
i can feel the weight of those things i
liked
i liked the idea that it you know any
particular morning
not to say i would do this necessarily
but that i could just kind of pack up
everything into my car and be on my way
and that's everything that's all i need
so
yeah i don't know so it's strange i
think i'm still
uh processing all of it you know in
terms of its ultimate
lessons no things do own you it's true
yeah yeah they have a weight for sure
yeah
chapter seven last moments by adisa
ten years ago i went to sierra leone
with isaiah washington on a documentary
film shoot and on that shoot uh that
shoot literally would change my life
uh not only did i get exposed to sierra
leone and
um the conditions over there because
they had just undergone a civil war
and isaiah was looking up his roots and
i was part of the documentary team
i had a great experience but when i came
back i had a near-death experience
because i had cotton virus over there
called the hantavirus and when i got
back to
l.a i mean i was just i was just
fatally ill and i had to be rushed to
the hospital i was in the icu
and my heart stopped beating three times
i had
multiple organ failure and i was in
really bad
shape and the doctors didn't think i was
gonna make it nobody thought i was gonna
make it so my mother at that time flew
up here
and uh people were just praying i mean i
was just in critical condition
and but miraculously i made it through
yeah i made it through did they know
what it was
they didn't at the time they didn't and
uh it was a good thing that i was at
what they called
uh was it danny freeman more hospital
and they were like oh thank god you
didn't go to like cedar cyanide
because the daniel freeman hospital they
could bring in other technicians from
everywhere like he could bring in people
from ucla they can bring in doctors from
usc to uh to help
on my case right whereas i've been
seaters they have like
clear rules about cedars-side doctors
working there and you can't bring others
in
but because i was at daniel freeman
hospital they were able to bring another
doctor so nobody knew what i had
all i knew was i had multiple organ
failure and my body was shutting down
and this one particular doctor stayed
with me and he had to restart my heart
three times in the middle of the night
and so yeah i know it looked like i was
on my deathbed
it looked like i was on my day and
actually i thought i was on my deathbed
too
the only thing kept me going was the
fact that because i one morning at one
point i remember myself making
um sort of this uh resolve
that like you know what i'm gonna if i'm
gonna die my last moments were in africa
my last moments were playing with
children my last moments were with
like you know um having fun
and sharing of my gifts with everybody
because that's where that's what i was
doing after
giving out soccer balls and i made some
serious relate some
nice relationships over there so i said
you know what if i gotta go
then so be it i had made it i had made
peace with it you know
and uh but it was another plan for me it
was another plan i'm here
and how long were you in the hospital i
was there for about uh
i was probably there for about seven to
eight weeks total
but for like three weeks i was sedated
and i was
under heavy sedation as the doctors
treated me and put me on dialysis and we
just
you know trying everything to fix me
trying everything to make me better but
nothing worked and they didn't know so
they said they just had to let it run
its course
and just let me be uh you know just let
me be
sort of get let my body fight it when i
got back
and i got well i shocked everybody
because i told my mother when to go back
to africa and she was like oh no you
can't go back to africa oh no you're not
going to do that to me again my mother's
beside herself
my father uh everybody tripped out i
mean they were like no you can't go back
because i got an opportunity to go back
with
um was it regina king yeah regina king
the actress
had invited me to go back and work with
her on her documentary
and so they were like no you can't go
back you can't go especially going back
to sierra leone in the same place
and so people were freaking out like
freaking out
and but i was resolved i was like you
know what i'm better
i can do this and i wanted to do this i
wanted to be there was some things that
had happened to me
by being sick you know like i was having
revelations around my life and what i
wanted to do with my life and
and how i wanted to show up and so
yeah and going back to africa was part
of it i think the light had turned on
more i'm not gonna say it was completely
different i mean i was like
i was already like a very positive
optimistic person
wanting to do things but i was probably
stopping myself like
the tournament in africa and working
with the kids i never thought i could do
that
you know like there was something about
the way i was living life that i felt
like
um that was larger than what i could do
right and so i started to so yes to
answer your question once i got better i
started to test the boundaries
more like around greatness and largeness
and saying that i can do it
i can do that why not right and so yeah
in that way
and then having to experience death also
i mean it just gives you this sense of
i'm not saying immortality but you to
experience and be that close to death
and to know that it can be snapped away
from you that at an instant
it kind of sharpened my focus about
living life
in the present moment to moment and
doing as much as i can in that moment
chapter 8 amy purdy's journey by barbara
seymour giordano
essentially amy's story is that at 19
she contracted meningitis
and she died
essentially and then was brought back
but she'd gone to the hospital
she what it does she was so advanced in
it
that the the um body tries to save the
organs and the blood rushes from it so
uh rushes from the vital organs and your
hands turn purple
her feet turn purple her cheeks and nose
and when it happens it's like frostbite
and so when they got her to the hospital
um
it was touch and go she she actually
did pass away very briefly and they
brought her back
um but it was touch and go for a long
long time
and then um in the end they had to
uh to amputate her legs from
the ankles down or the calves down
and uh both of them
and but everything else was saved i mean
she did have a lot of other
she lost hearing in her ear she had all
of these issues
so here she was this story and she'd
done a lot already at this point
you know she had been in a madonna video
and she'd done all these things
but i had to because she'd done so many
things i had to weigh and measure what
was important in the story
and that's where i had to trust my
intuition and where i could actually
look at this guide of the hero's journey
because
her life story this particular incident
fit perfectly in it so it isn't a life
story it's not an
autobiography it's a moment in time
and a great speech is it doesn't try to
cover too much it's a
very narrow subject and this narrow
subject for amy was her life
this life where she no longer she had to
let go of the old amy
to embrace the new amy and we wrote that
in there and every time she goes
every time i say that line i cry and i
was like good
yay but that was the middle part
of the hero's journey the very point
where she then begins to embrace the
journey that she's on so even though you
go over the threshold right
you go through the steps of and i can't
remember
all of them but there's that low point
in the circle right
and that's where she began to rise like
a phoenix from the ashes
and she began to bring back what she
learned
of course to cross back over and bring
the elixir back
to the world which was a speech so it
was really about
her experience and what she learned and
the struggles that she went through and
how
hard it was but yet how she wouldn't
change a thing
right and so i had to figure out do we
keep the madonna video part in there
because my speakers use slides
right the majority i think i've only
worked with a couple who have not
um in high resolution photos i don't
occasionally i let them use text if it's
important to the story
but the the images are wallpaper that
really um helps the emotion stick
so the story will be stickier if the if
the resolutions and the photos
of the resolution the resolution of the
photos are super
emotional the photos themselves and she
had a lot of emotional photos
and so uh we
chose the the most important parts of
the story so we had to take
them the audience low to the lowest
point to bring them back
up again in the journey where she was
resurrected so she does the ted talk
and then what's the response within
what amount of time so this is so
exciting because it's a tedx talk right
so this is 2011 and
and she's like okay i did the talk it's
been posted it took like a month before
they posted it great
and this was probably so we did it in
may it probably went up in june
crickets
she got about 20 000 hits and
through december and then i think it was
in december
uh all of a sudden she calls me like
completely worked up oh my god barbara
what she go look at the ted talk
they had taken the tedx talk and put it
on the ted
page oh and they don't do that anymore
but they they did it for her
and so that's where you can see it is on
the ted page they
put it on the ted page
and once that happened it went viral wow
and she's like people are writing in
arabic like a month later
it just started going everywhere and we
were watching it tick through like
you know 30 forty thousand fifty
thousand by the hour
and we're like oh my gosh this is so
exciting and
yeah so she just captured the hearts and
minds of so many people
her story and it's it's remarkable story
and she's a
remarkable woman just a really beautiful
on the outside but
equally as beautiful on the inside
chapter 9 instinct by waleed azami
i work with madonna and i worked on a
world tour and i befriended
a friend of mine now a really good
friend jamie king who is a creative
director of
the tour and like so many other artists
and he so
just glaze over that real fast so he
would watch me
um come in and look at everything like
everything i would like
inspect like crazy because i knew where
i was
i knew that i'm gonna learn so much from
this woman
and um i left that job
and i left that job and out of the blue
he just texted me one day he's like hey
walid how are you
let's go get dinner i want to know what
you're up to and so i went to dinner
with him
and i drove up from anaheim at the
anaheim
i think i was in whatever anaheim our
fullerton one of those two cities
in orange county at the time and i drove
up to la
and i met him for dinner but what he did
not know
is that i was dead broke broke broke
broke
okay and this is pretty much right at
the birth
of the 2008 great recession
so i had quit being a music video
director's assistant
i had done some pa jobs um i was the
worst pa you could ever hire on
i mean the amount of effort i put into
not looking busy it was exhausting and i
thought
just do the work you know but like
trying to walk back and forth
like look busy without really doing the
stuff
so jamie had called me like i want to
know what you're up to
and um he had a plan and
he had a plan so we went up
and had dinner and another friend dog
was a very talented director and joined
us also
and he asked me um what are you doing
now i'm broke at this time i have a
credit card and i probably have like
three four hundred dollars in my savings
and that was it
because you don't get paid much as an
assistant in hollywood you know
and so um and i had quit that to try to
do some behind the scenes video
like mtv's making the video and i got
one or two jobs and then it just stopped
but i didn't know that the recession was
born you know
and so i had stopped for everyone but
people hadn't been honest about it yet
that
there something happened overnight right
and um so i went to dinner with them
and they were asking me like so what are
you doing and i and i would say
well i want to and he's like shut up and
i thought what
and i said and i was so confused because
i thought hey you're asking me
what i'm doing or what i want to do and
i'm telling you you're telling me shut
up
and we did this a few times back and
forth and he said don't talk again
until you're actually doing it
because trying is lying and i don't know
if he actually said trying is lying or
if i pick that up somewhere else but
but the meaning is the same trying is
lying so you're doing it
or you're lying to yourself but you're
not lying to me
right and he and he was really rough
with me so
he broke me that night and he rebuilt me
that night and he gave me
one of the best lessons i've ever
learned in my life
i actually practiced it without really
knowing what it was
and he gave me this thing i'm going to
tell you right now and he said
no matter what country you're from no
matter what faith you practice or you
don't practice
um gender national uh
anything doesn't matter what
socioeconomic level one of the first
things
that any human being learns one of the
first words
is no because we are told no
so many times and he said it's not the
hearing no
that's bad it's why we're telling people
no no i don't people think you're a bad
baby i don't people think that i'm a bad
mother
i don't want you know be a good little
girl and be quiet
right be a good boy don't show your
emotions
be tough and so we are the only living
creatures
on this planet that teach our children
to kill their instincts
and so we're sending people out there to
conform
and you have to to a certain extent not
to be a freak in society right
but you we're sending people out there
and
we're taking away their greatest tool
that fight or flight
you know and so he said if your
instincts tell you
to do something go do it i don't care if
you think you're gonna look like a fool
if your instincts tell you don't get in
this car right now
don't get in that car let everyone think
you're crazy but
that is a direct phone call from you to
god or allah or energy or
or the universe or whatever you want
to think is bigger than you okay a
greater power and he said that's a
direct phone call that you're getting at
any moment
so he gave me examples he said how many
times have you thought about somebody
and then they text you and you're like
that's so weird i was thinking about you
it's like that's a connection how many
times has a mother
been at work and she's like something is
wrong something is wrong with my baby
and they call the baby said i'm like
yeah that was a small accident you know
he or she is fine
that mother knows there's a connection
right
and so he said
the the closest you'll ever be to god
or again whatever i don't want people
getting lost on that part of it or
whatever higher power
mother nature is when you listen to your
instincts
and he's like if you want to photograph
everybody in all green paint
go do it something is telling you this
is going to be good for your career
now that night so
that's what i mean by he broke me and
then he rebuilt me and he was setting it
in an infrastructure that i had already
been using
and how i i've acted in a lot in my
earlier career
my school and everything sorry that's
okay and so he had set
like the the structure the
infrastructure of like
things that i a guideline and i had been
doing it but i didn't know this was my
instincts
okay and um i went home
thank god he paid for dinner because i
did not have money to even pay for my
portions and we had like drinks and
dessert and appetizers i'm like oh my
god
you know that's expensive and he set me
on my way
and for like a week after i had
um this weird feeling apparently was my
instincts but this weird form feeling
that i should buy a camera
but i didn't when i tell you i did not
even know that
a camera you can detach a lens from a
camera
like a dslr or i guess mirrorless now
whatever i did not even know you could
do that i didn't know what an iso was
i knew nothing nothing about a camera
and so but i had this feeling go buy a
camera
jobs are not coming in rent is coming up
and i only have a few hundred bucks on a
credit card left
and i sat on it and i pushed it down
and it just kept persisting kept
persisting for
i want to say a week week and a half or
something like that
this feeling was there and it would not
go away
and i don't know what made me but i
decided to listen to my instincts
and i went into a camera shop and
and i i'm such so naive but
i went in and i said um i said
hi um i have two thousand dollars
my credit card and i said i have two
thousand dollars and i want to
be a photographer and he sold me like
1998 dollars and whatever there was
nothing else left in the store to buy
not even double a batteries because it
was like
it wasn't i mean they maxed out my card
and i bought a a 40d which is not even a
real it was like a prosumer camera
and it was a good camera but i'm just
saying it wasn't like
it was whatever it was like a rebel
today or something and
i had no i sat in my car and i remember
the most nauseous feeling and i thought
what did i do
i even and now i can't even get a cash
advance on my last credit card
because i maxed that sucker out i went
home and
just i was just i was a mess
and what a dramatic person but i was a
mess you know and i thought
man i don't even know how to turn this
thing
on like no joke i have no idea how to
turn this thing
i did not know what a single i didn't
know a single
thing okay but
but i started shooting things like um
leaves on a tree and a trail of ants and
it was all horrible pictures
i got a call because i wanted to do
behind the scenes video
and i got a call because of a friend of
a friend of a friend they were like his
wallet there i'm like
right and i was like yes what are you
selling stranger exactly
and they said hey somebody said you have
a video camera
and at the time it was like the uh mini
dv tape so
they were like hey you i heard you have
a um an hd
camera and because everyone was using
the panasonic dvx100 which was like not
fully hd i think
whatever but i said yes
and i was so excited because i can buy
food now okay
and put food in the fridge and they said
usher needs somebody to come to the
kodak theater
right now and i'm packing everything in
a bag throwing everything
didn't even have camera bags like i put
them in a gym bag and stuff and i'm
about to close the door
and that weird feeling in my
gut said usher doesn't know why
you're hired it says manager go
get that stupid camera you just bought
to the still camera
and i grabbed it and i
ran on the car and i remember i had a
little blackberry curve with the ball
and i wrote f-stop means this
iso means this and you know aperture
means this whatever
and um and that was pretty much our
shutter speed and and and
i i went there i went underground like
two three levels i said hi to usher
and i'm one of those people that when
i'm nervous i look
like i look like i'm hiding a bomb i'm
telling you it's like this
it just looks so bad you know
and i don't have a poker face whatsoever
and
i was just shooting stuff and i decided
to put the video camera on a tripod in
the corner so now it looks like a
security camera
but uh sure has the footage and i wish i
had it but um
of me trying to figure this out and
looking at my blackberry mic okay
this button did this and i'll take
pictures and i didn't even know
that um i had a one gigabyte
card cf card so my compact flash was one
and i was shooting on jpeg small
did not even know about these settings
that they existed or that raw was such a
thing
okay and i'm shooting and i'm shooting
machine gun style because
i'm banking on quantity here not quality
and pictures are like because they have
the the neon tubes
pictures are coming out like all
different colors but it is not the color
you want to see
and usher's coming out blurry um because
i'm apparently on like like
not even at 40 i think it was like it
was basically it was i pretty much
almost had the bold button you know like
it was just
dragging the shutter everything was
blurry and i'm
ramping up the iso as high as possible
i'm just hitting any button
okay and usher looks at me and says what
f stop are you using
and yo when i tell you i have mastered
how to die on the inside
and keep a calm face i think i'm keeping
a calm face
i that gut feeling said
walk away yo i was on autopilot i don't
think that was valid
that day okay i was on autopilot that
gut feeling said walk away and
i remember it was instant and said it's
better that he thinks you're a crazy
artist
than someone who has no idea which was
the truth okay
and um actually now i think both are
true but
but um i went upstairs
i looked up again because i wrote f-stop
but i had to look up i'm like what did
this mean
you know with all these performers
street performers
on and i'm like come on verizon you know
like give me the reception and
everything
and i went back down in case he asked me
and i wrote it down
because i'd be like f-stop is this i'm
like i am using
5.6 you know but he didn't ask me again
and i just kept shooting
i went home i went home and
um sewed down and i looked at all the
pictures and i did not even know that
photoshop
exists i did not know photoshop was a
thing
the whole institute of adobe
was not even in my in my spectrum
whatsoever okay
so i decided to download all the
pictures
open them up individually inside the
preview
like what you would open up a pdf in and
so you have the option of
bringing down contrast exposure
saturation
hue and that's about it and i'm looking
at these pictures i'm like
i don't know where usher is because
everything is blurry i can't tell
you know anything and out of that i
probably pulled under 10 images
that you can identify it was usher and
that he was actually in focus
on accident okay and
i pulled up about 10 of them and this is
me opening a a picture one at a time i'm
like
no next it was a disaster okay and then
i
it was like i did not even know such a
thing of lightroom existed so i would
take them in one folder copy them
paste them into a second folder as i'm
eliminating
which pictures i want you know and
narrowing down
and i found about 10 12 maybe nine i
don't know
but i i opened them up in that preview
panel
and i thought oh my god they're every
color
under the rainbow and i remember
again that that instinct was really
in play and i was like just turn it all
black and white
and i turned them i desaturated all of
them and i boosted the contrast a little
bit they were already blurry sometimes
and they were already high high high iso
so super grainy
and i sent them to benny medina who was
usher's manager at the time now he does
jlo
and i think jlo only and um
they called me within like 30 minutes
and they said
waleed i don't know how you guessed it
but we sent the pictures to usher and
his whole new thing for the new album
is old hollywood oh wow and he wants
these black and white
grainy imperfect images and so we want
to know
would you be willing to work with him
and be his personal photographer
oh my gosh and that like that to me is
like that's
the perfect story in my career of
following your instincts
and just having faith in it i mean i
know that people are listening to this
and like he's crazy like how am i going
to take that chance but
that was me just following instincts
from the start
and going there's a there's this weird
feeling and i don't know what's going on
i'm going to follow it
and every single day i would learn one
new thing on youtube
and i would type things like what does
exposure mean
and i would study it because a history
major you know ask me about civil war
i'll tell you everything about it you
know but
and that was um and i would learn that
one thing
and then i was not allowed to go to bed
until i learned one new thing every
single day
so after a week it was no big deal after
a month it was a no big deal
by the end of the second month i started
it started adding up the things that i
knew
you know and so usher would say hey
let's shoot over there i'm like no let's
not
because i hadn't even reached that yet i
was just on natural window light
you know and i was like no that's not
let's just stand over here and do it and
i would just
so whatever i learned the night before i
would
practice it on him the next day and he's
like you have such a vast style like
you do so many things i'm like dude you
don't even know like i'm on youtube
every night
like learning things and then coming
downstairs
and practicing it on you and i learned
how to
photograph on tour with usher